I think it's just perfect just like it
is and I'd hate to see it I'd hate to
see a CG effects in it you know cuz they
just are not as real as the real thing
the background of the moon was real
background of the real moon that we
photographed with a telephoto lens this
background is all fake because I wanted
something that was better than we could
have really ever seen in real life so we
could light it and get the colors right
and get a really magical the feeling
that Steven wanted almost like a dream
and the way we did these was by making
model bikes we had five of them for the
five kids that are flying I want to talk
about this
ét guy because if he doesn't he's not
convincing as a character you have no
movie and this is something that's a
puppet and I know there's we had a
little item in variety today the
Tennessee you had said that it on the
set he didn't look that great until it
moved and it was like magic I mean right
in front of you something like this
that's just sort of static suddenly when
all the puppeteers are working together
and Stephens directing it you see oh my
god this is like a real thing and then
it takes over and it stops and goes back
to being this puppet when they were
shooting et go down at the set it was
just amazing because it was a dead you
can't imagine the din of sound there
were nine puppeteers off-camera
looking at their monitor they were
listening to stephen direct them they
could see he all that all the facial
movements had to be in sync with each
other just think about it blinking an
eye if you think about blinking your eye
when you move your head everything had
to seem I hate to use the word human but
we had to humanize him so the puppeteers
were doing a beautiful job all the
handwork when it you know Stephen
realized very early on that the hand
work needed to be more realistic so he
used a mime artist for the hands so he
had different versions of et there were
the people in the suits Pat Bowlen who
was the main et actor who was actually
inside one of the rubber suits from time
to time and then there was I don't much
sure how many puppets they had to work
with you and know Dennis
on the set and when they would shoot
they would shoot one roll of film at a
time that's ten minutes and they shot
and shot and shot an individual motion
again and again and again until they got
it right go home phone home phone home
20 30 40 50 60 times until they got the
arm going up and saying phone home I was
very new to mixing films when this
project was put before us and at times
we would have John I would have John
Williams CD to my left
Steven seated to my right buzz Knutson
the dialog mixer to his right and then
Bob glass was beyond that and the five
of us would line up on the console and
some of these scenes were just so
incredible
Steven would be conducting a little
louder a little softer all of this on my
right side and John would be over here
sort of nodding or whatever and I'd be
looking at the scene and we'd we'd get a
few new shots in the scene with that
would that would be always be the thing
that would surprise us in those days now
when you mix a movie usually all of the
shots are there when you're actually
mixing the movie but we'd be pre dubbing
we'd be getting things together for
quite a long period of time and there'd
be sections where we would be looking at
leader and there wouldn't be anything it
would just be sort of this pale yellow
there's a shot coming some day kind of
reminder or hopefully hopefully exactly
and then on successive days we'd have
more shots we'd have more things filled
in we get to see more of what was
actually going on and anyway mixing with
John to my left and Steven to my right
and getting into some of these scenes it
was just remarkable because we'd all be
feeling it we'd all be experiencing it
Steven would be conducting me I'd have
tears running down the side of my face
and we were living
the experience of this movie as we were
making it early so I certainly was and I
mean I guess my cohorts had seen it many
more times than I had but it was an
incredible experience